which character in the batman could turn
out to be the hero stewart sidekick
robin is he hiding in plain sight keep
watching for the fan theories that say
just that batman and his major villains
supporting casts gadgets and methods are
a known quantity for moviegoers by now
but it seems like bringing batman's
famous sidekick to the screen is more of
a challenge for many filmmakers despite
the fact that robin is an immediately
identifiable pop culture icon his time
on the big screen has been relatively
scarce christopher nolan's trilogy of
batman films for example only included
robin in the form of joseph
gordon-levitt's character whose real
name is revealed at the end of the dark
knight rises try my legal name
you should use your full name i like
that name
robin
director joel schumacher included the
character in batman forever and batman
and robin but since then the most who've
seen of this brightly garbed orphan
circus acrobat has been a monument to
his off-screen death in batman v
superman dawn of justice the exclusion
of robin continues in the batman it's
arguably the grimmest and most serious
big screen take on batman yet and it can
be a little hard to imagine a
swashbuckling robin in it but with
future sequels almost certainly on the
way fans already speculating about how
matt reeves might find a way to link
robin up to this brooding version of
batman particularly given the dark new
twists already given to characters like
riddler and the penguin
some say he's already been introduced
if you've seen the batman you remember
gotham mayor mitchell the riddler's
first victim and his grieving son bruce
wayne obviously feels a connection to
the boy's grief as it mirrors his own
following the traumatic death of his
parents that alone doesn't make the
younger mitchell a prospective robin but
as one phantom reddit points out there
are other potential clues pointing to
the kids possible future as a caped
crime fighter i mean they showed him
multiple times throughout the movie
bruce felt connected with him for being
an orphan the kid was wearing a red
ninja suit and wielded a katana at the
beginning i mean come on just a little
resemblance
while the classic dick grayson version
of robin isn't known to fight with the
katana the damien wayne version does the
stronger clue though is a kid wearing
red others see the character as merely a
reflection of bruce wayne in keeping
with the story's theme of batman on an
unbreakable cycle of violence and grief
one user wrote i really just took it as
that kid is a reflection of what
happened to bruce wayne the cycle is
repeating itself batman wasn't stopping
it in his current form if mitchell's son
isn't robin maybe someone else is
there's a new recruit to the gang seen
early in the film who seems visibly
uncomfortable with the actions of the
others and even hesitates to beat up an
innocent victim he ends up running away
from batman rather than fighting notably
he wears a red hood and the movie
focuses on him just enough to make him
stick out in the memory of viewers the
character is played by actor jayla kurgo
who is probably by coincidence now
playing tim drake the third robin on hbo
max's titans since titans definitely
doesn't fit into the same continuity as
the batman it would seem unlikely that
both franchises would have the same
actor playing robin if the younger
mitchell doesn't end up accepting the
mantle of robin nor the unnamed gang
member it wouldn't be the first time
that batman fans will be disappointed by
what they thought was a clue about
future characters remember the character
of coleman reese in the dark knight he's
a wayne industries employee who attempts
to blackmail the billionaire playboy
with information about his secret
identity at the time there was lots of
fan speculation that because mr reese
sounds a lot like mysteries he would be
the riddler in a future film he wasn't
they're trying to kill me or maybe
batman could save you on the other hand
all those theories about barry kyogen's
role in the batman were proven true so
you never know young mitchell's red
halloween costume and personal tragedy
could be a red herring or maybe he will
be robin either way for now it's fun to
speculate on whether or not such small
details of the batman could be hints
about developments later on
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]